welcome to the Von cast in the in the BR
app um I have a very special guest
that's going to join me today but first
I wanted to talk about the game on
Sunday Night Football um Lo another loss
to the Bengals man this uh this week um
you know during that game like we had
moments of U of playing like the team
that I know we can be but um there were
other moments in the game where it just
didn't allow us to gain momentum um we
had really good first on all three
phases but just wasn't enough to to beat
the Bengal um they're a good team you
know I don't want to give any poster
board material to those guys or anything
like that but I just feel like if we
play to the best of our ability like we
should beat them and I'm sure all Team
all all teams around the league feel
like that but you know we got Josh Allen
and our offense has it's it's magic in
the bottle at any given moment you know
our defense we have we have all the we
have all the pieces to be a competitive
defense in the league and you know we
just have so many players and I'm in the
locker room with these guys each and
every week and I just feel like you know
it's it's just it's still just a matter
of time before we explode but you know
we are running out of time to get it
done um you know no need to sound an
alarm or anything like that it's we're
still in great position to do all the
things that that we set out to do before
the season um it's just you know time to
do it and it'll be a great week to do it
this weekend so Denver Broncos my old
team you know we'll get into it uh later
in the show but um yeah it was it was a
a tough loss especially for me you know
um missing that tackle at the end of the
game I just feel like you know those are
the tackles that that I normally make um
not gonna get into to schemes or who I
was looking at who I was supposed to be
looking at it was just I had two guys on
my side that that I had I had the tight
end and and the running back and you
know and then all of a sudden you you're
one on one with Joe Mixon and you know I
just got to be able to make that play
and you know I I'll be able to make it
in the future just got to keep going um
you know I felt good going to the game
it's probably the the best that I felt
since I've been back but still still a
ways to go to uh you know to be the type
of player that I want to be and to be
the type of player that I know I can be
so you know on to the next one you know
the the journey keeps going um you're
never you know out of the fight so you
just have to keep on fighting keep on
grinding that's what I've been doing my
whole entire uh NFL career my My Little
League career my college and high school
career so that's just the story of gotta
keep going and you know now on to my
special guest this week Cam
Jordan is my guy man I know I'm on and
off the football field he's helped me
with numerous things man he's a eight
time Pro Bowl defensive end um the New
Orleans Saints career sack leader Cam
Jordan how's it going
bro man you know it's going it's going
good we we're blessed you know we just
blessed to be in the NFL blessed to be
here and you know blessed to be on vcast
finally I've been seeing you you've been
doing your thing for a while finally got
that invite must be doing something
right I appreciate you for coming man I
know you're a podcaster too and I did
your podcast last week so it's coming to
be like a weekly thing man like we we we
we podcasting weekly you know I text you
whenever we're I'm playing one of the
teams that you that you're playing man
and you know starting to come it's
starting to become a weekly thing man
absolutely bro like you know your your
Deep dive your deep dive in the team is
is awesome you like C what you what were
you thinking on this move I'm like I
would never even thought to do that
because I don't think offensive lineman
matter
enough no yeah you just R you just run
straight through him Man games are games
are a little bit different man you you
just bully the guys and trash them and
all game long and then you know hit him
with a I seen a a chop hump I I seen a
chop hump in there you got the spin you
got you you got whatever it takes to be
the tackle I might say that you got
whatever it takes and these some of the
things that we've talked about at my
pastor Summit you know I wanted to tell
you again I appreciate you for coming
out um he has a he had a very important
role in this year's Pastor Summit um he
was working with all the young guys on
the another side of the field Demarcus
word wasn't there and cam Cam Jordan fed
that void um like no other could man and
I appreciate you coming I've said it to
you so many times and I appreciate you
for coming man in this area of of
quarterbacks dropping back more than
ever how important is it to help the
next generation of defensive ends learn
learn the skills that's necessary to be
successful in the
NFL man you you say they dropping back
more than ever I feel like they get the
ball out faster more than ever last last
three or four weeks I I had uh Jordan
love at Green Bay I had ba beant bant
still don't know how to say his name for
Chicago Bears beijan I hope I'm not
disrespecting his last name he hell of a
young player uh CJ St
and and like just the likes of them bro
all these quarterbacks I'm like o
previous weeks you know we we we
watching everything around like oh sacks
are averaging three and a half seconds
to get you know guys are going at seven
to nine steps last four weeks bro we've
been averaging 2.3 or some joint like
that like it's frustrating as pass rure
but you get into the you know you get
into the stretch of quarterbacks where
now it's time to start making some money
after this week apparently because now
we got Josh dubs who's on that same heke
you know we got we got excited because
you know you know cousin is a guy who's
going to take seven seven step drops
going do the right reads again prolific
passer guy who guy who's going to make
you work for each and every play but now
you got Josh dub so now I'm going back
to like Arizona Arizona Cardinal field
I'm going back to Steelix field um but
the young guys this next
Generation it's it's it's pivot you see
these guys going off this year like you
know denell Hunter already had 10 sacks
Josh Allen probably at around 10 sacks
um TJ watt you know eight or nine
whatever it is uh Micah it's it's all
these young guys going crazy right now
uh my guy Carl Granderson already at
five and a half it's like you got seven
seven games left I'm trying to see where
the new ceiling gonna be the way these
guys going
crazy um I'm just I'm just overly
excited to see where they at so any any
information I can give or whatever it is
I'm with it I'm all for the dline
excelling as long as they don't Excel
against the
Saints no I I feel like it's I feel like
it's twofold I feel like you know I I
give them information in exchange for
information you know it's a you never
you you never stop learning so it has
never been the the teach clinic at the
vill pastor suit it's always been you
know link and learn like I learn
something every time I'm out there and
and the stay and play a long time in the
NFL you have to have that ability you
you can never say I know it all like
even to this day like I still don't know
it all 13 years in the league I try to I
try to find something and and whoever is
having success in the National Football
League and it's a lot of young pass
rushers out there going crazy so I just
try to that's just my way of of giving
back to the game that is given so much
to me man and I appreciate you for being
part of that man but you're a podcaster
now I'm a podcaster um I came in your
show last week and I want to say you
know thank you for returning the favor
for me man um growing up in Minnesota
your dad was your dad played for the
Vikings tight end for the Vikings how
was how was that bro I can't even
imagine like Dad play in the NFL bro
that had to be that had to be you know
the subject to talk about at school
especially during the fall especially
during the fall growing up playing
football like I'm I'm sure you say man
my dad plays football for the Vikings
how was that
bro no um I think I think they did a
great job of sort of keeping us
sheltered away from that like it wasn't
like now where you know you got all all
types of social media Tik Tok Instagram
you know twitch caffeine all these you
know all these platforms to get you know
YouTube whatever it is um you know back
then it was TV radio and what like we we
had a grow with d d love internet you
know what I'm saying so we didn't even
have internet while he was in the league
think think about that like just the the
the whole space that was transformed
with with that alone so it was easy to
shelter him off from like hey you know
Dad plays football but you go to the you
know key games you go to whatever it is
it's not like this week where now it's
like you know this day and age where
it's a whole production we didn't go to
Every home game you know like that just
wasn't it wasn't realistic it was like
all right well he has a game so we'll
see him when he gets home no I think
they did I think my parents did a great
job of sort of like being able to Shield
us away from all that so I was four or
five years old when he retired and year
later we moved back to you know we moved
from Minnesota where he'd been his
entire career back to Arizona so you you
you leave leave a lot of that fan lore
you know that that all inspiring your
dad is back there you know so you get to
Arizona it's just another day he's an
engineer he's working he comes home for
us our daily our daily lives never
changed it was like oh dad play football
cool next you know it wasn't until you
got to your High School junior high high
school was like oh that didn't just play
that was that dude in you know that was
that was putting in significant work to
be a be a pro bowler you like you don't
really understand until you you know get
to that level it's like oh shoot because
I mean I feel like a lot of kids like
now Madden is prevalent Madden is the to
play you know you kids seven eight nine
years old oh man I got I got you I got a
a mut card on you or I you know I'm
doing I'm doing uh fantasy football or
whatever it is but that's another
connection us growing up there was there
wasn't fantasy football there wasn't you
know we were playing techmoo when the
numbers you know when the last names
didn't even pop up it was like number 83
score you like I think that's dad you
know like you can make you can make up
your own story line that way I think
that's
that you know now kids are like playing
mad and you know my son like dad I got
you coming off the edge I'm like yeah
you know like yeah you do you know like
there there's Pride there you know like
I I didn't have that growing up you know
just in terms of playing video games it
just is what it is um but so that that
that connection sort of lost it was like
it literally took me probably to high
school like oh shoot D that was really
that guy and even then he was trying to
be my coach and I was like hey man you
play tight end I'm a defensive man for a
reason like I like you stay over on that
side now but he he know though man he
know I feel like even though I play
defensive end like I could give tips on
if you know offensive lineman wide
receivers quarterbacks whatever you know
I just feel like that's that's been my
life man that's been my life not to side
with your dad or anything like that I'm
just I'm just saying man you have credit
you have credited your your father's
work ethic as being key to your success
you know now being a father yourself is
that something you you also you know try
to instill and your kids I heard you you
know say um on the podcast last week you
said no matter what I'm going to get up
and cook breakfast you know before my
before my kids go to school and before I
go to work man is is that like part of
the the things that you want your kids
to see about you know you being in the
league but still you have time to be a
dad yeah man in fact last week I took uh
you know my son's eight and he's growing
at like you know just a rapid rate dude
the monster name's tank um and you know
he was he was complaining about how his
knees and ankles hurt or whatever those
he's got growing pains right so after
breakfast was that last Saturday I was
like all right man I was like you know
we did we whatever whatever the
breakfast was I was like all right I was
like you tough right he was like yeah
man he's like he's like Dad I'm just
like my body sore I said all right let's
go get in the cold tub you know so I
drove him to the facility we hopped in
the cold tub and I don't get the cold
tub so that's how you know that's real
love like I don't believe I don't
believe in it I think hot tub can s
solve it just just just as well I think
my man in the cold tub and we we tell
you the time of my life like we got
there probably like s 7 o' 7 10 our
trainers are over there looking at me
put dump my son in this cold tub
probably looking like a terrible father
but I put him in the cold tub like you
got to be in there for two minutes I was
like just two man and he he dad you
didn't tell me this was Arctic I'm like
Arctic okay he's like it's no you don't
even get the cold tub I was like I don't
I was like you know what I threw gray on
got in the cold tub with them my man was
upset just Dad you this this is not okay
I said bro you gotta sit in there like
you got to get your waist down I was
like yo if you're if you're aching this
is going to help you with your aching
Maybe minute and a half in he jumps to
the hot tub bro I like we got to go two
minutes so make him do two minutes from
there I'm like bro like this is
something that he's he's probably gonna
be mentally scarred for for the rest of
his life but at the same time like he's
like you know a week later he's like hey
Dad if my body starts hurting do I have
to go back to C tub like well did it
help and if it helps then yes if not
then no we we'll keep to the hot tub
he's like I think I can go back to the
hot tub of course you think you can go
to the hot tub everybody can go to the
hot tub that's why Daddy go to the hot
tub but I just hope these are like the
little things that they take away with
the dope thing is you know my man's
eight years old so he's gonna have some
like core memories of me playing
football you know I plan I'm playing for
another few years eventually like it
won't be like you know me at five years
old whatever like I think I remember a
game you gon be like oh I remember when
I was here and doing this and I met I
remember meeting him like there's gonna
be there gonna be some core memories
that that are ingrained in
him yeah 100% man those are going to be
C Core memories man that's that's dope
to as dop CH even thinking about he's
eight years old like he he's almost
grown man he's gonna remember all of
that stuff man how does it how does it
feel to have that that Dynamic come full
a
circle man uh yeah you know you got when
you got a legacy holder like you know
shout out to all the all the dad that
have a boy I feel like every man needs
needs to raise a man you know like this
just navigating this path especially
especially now uh like again we bring up
probably beat social media to to horse
run but that's not something that I grew
up in you know you didn't grow up with
just you know YouTube available on iPad
you know we had to walk around third
fourth grade with maybe second grade you
know with the Walkman or something like
that we we didn't just have you know we
we had a fight to put 12 songs on a uh
on a UBS you we used to burn CDs they're
not going through none of that it's just
readily available on their iPad little
man got a iPad you know like this this
just the wild time we live in but it's
so awesome to see he's able to now he
plays flag football his last game you
know he had they had like a double
header playoff game one1 lost lost the
second one but he had like two picks
like pivotal picks and I'm just like
sitting there like hey man good for you
you know like it's just great to see and
eight years old I'm not yeah I'm I'm not
pressing him but I'm I'm I'm like hey
man as long as you give it your all
that's all I can ask for and he's amped
up he looked like every deep tackle
that's ever made you know a significant
tackle he's kicking legs he's hyped up
he looked like my guy Malcolm roach
after he makes a tackle like he he's
pumped the whole team up like bro you
got a whole another play but that's it's
it's fire to see that really brings it
full circle I'm like dang like is this
what I look like when I was playing
playing a little peeeee ball or like is
this this how pops felt and now I'm just
watching my guy just like oh If he if he
was eight years old and he was like
eight years older like 16 17 like you
know those few players that had like
kids in high school I'm not going to lie
you yeah as much as I love football my
man would have a have a game Friday
night and the coach tell me no I'm
taking that fine every time like like
I'm I'm watch I'm trying to see all
their events you know like you got to
gotta be there for them like that's
that's that's the whole point of having
a legacy retainer that's the whole point
of having a fam is to you know try and
be that Supporting Cast for for your uh
for your team they're there for me on
Sundays how could I not be there for
them on their game day one% I don't
think I don't think coach would would
find you for that man I I think when you
break it down to him like that I don't
think he will find you for that man has
your son ever G ever gave you uh grief
on your celebrations has he ever tried
to help you with your
celebrations n n luckily lucky we don't
DJ from the past you know what I'm
saying we we just keep stacking him
thing and it's it's goes through he's
like Dad I Ain see it today like he'll
challenge me on like hey he didn't see
it enough he like Dad I a see it today I
hey hey relax brother you ain't gonna
get a sack every time and I stress it I
stress it to theth degree I said hey man
to get to third down there's first and
second and he's like yeah that's why I'm
goingon to be a linebacker I'm going to
hit everybody I said no that makes that
makes sense we could we could also work
on this jumper like your mom's play ball
at Ruckers for a reason baby like she
chosen now yes like Legacy Vibes I got I
got a perfect coach I I saw her you know
I was like oh like I'm glad I fell in
love with you because like you
McDonald's All-American from Cali you
know like Triple Threat all you I need
all them coaching skills Bae like that's
that's your role so she got all four of
them kids dribbling we we need that
we're here for the finer nuances I need
I need I really want him to be a three
like he wants to be a three Tech and I
want him to be just a wing three you
know what I'm saying I'm trying to
stretch that thing yeah yeah man you get
to play inside you get to play in in
arenas all year around hot cold you got
constant temperature every every
everywhere you go travel across the
world man I mean what you you spraying
the wrist you don't play the game they
really do not man but um you know back
to celebrations you gave your dad grief
on on some of celebrations
too man he had zero swag back in the
[Laughter]
G look at him he did all that work for
the for the teddy and then just he want
to go hug a
teammate ah come on at least hit me with
a cold handshake give me something
Daddy hey man hey he was tired when he
got down there man we we all know what
it feel like
hey you see hey you see him out run the
safety up top hey you did damage you
deserve to
celebrate he like go go take Chris
Carter give him hey dap him up something
cold man give him a hug hey lean up lean
to the draft did you think that you were
that you did you think you was going to
Minnesota no I was praying I wasn't
going to
Minnesota uh he Christi Ponder man
anywhere cold I was trying not to go
come on Van you know you've known me for
13 years
now I'm not the one if it's if it's sub
75 I throw a sweater
on I'm in the house with a sweater on
and it was 80 degrees out today yeah I I
knew I I had it was Denver and buffalo
so I just I just had I accepted it from
from day one but Denver it really wasn't
that cold and I feel like now like you
know if you if you're in the league you
you you're going to have to play Eight
Games I mean in the NFC South like y'all
y'all got d y got domes everywhere y'all
don't y'all don't play in the y'all
don't play in that much code out there
in the NFC South but everywhere else
you're gonna get at least eight games in
the Cod no matter no matter who you
played
for every year that schedule come out i'
be over there looking at the days oh we
got we got the Jets when oh okay okay
okay okay September that's cool that's
cool oh oh we got we got Green Bay when
ah
October ah come on Lord do your thing
baby hey it uh man I just I just to be
honest
I've accepted the cold weather I I
really look at how many how many
artificial turf fields I'mma play on
like now it's like not to that point
okay I look at the schedule I be like
okay like turf turf turf oh I got grass
right here grass uh Turf again turf turf
turf turf but we play on Turf so you got
you gota kind of accept that now you
gota accept I I I you know me bro like I
try to be with the people and I know our
compatriots and constituents love the
idea of grass but for our get off
especially for you your get off is aite
your first three steps is damn near
unmatched for you to say grass is wild
to me like I them TR I like I them grass
fields that I be on bro so one or two
get offs a game you take off and your
footing is not
there what are we doing yeah I mean you
got so much power I mean bro you got so
much power coming out of that that
three-point stance or that two-point
stance is going it's going to happen
sometimes but the overall feel like when
you turning and you going around the
corner like it doesn't put as much
stress on the body when you going at
high speeds like that then you start
stopping start stopping like I feel like
on grass it feels you know better to me
I I don't know I just just when I see
the when I see the artificial turf feels
and you warm up it's just at this point
you know it's just I'm a grass guy I
really am a grass and Denver you know we
had grass San Diego was grass Oakland
was grass now both now both of those
teams were changed but they were both
grass and uh Kansas City were grass so
no no Oakland was
grass I only played on I only played on
the baseball diamond once my whole
entire career oh yeah me it was terrible
I do miss that Oakland Stadium though I
really
why that diamond I missed that Oakland
Stadium one of my favorite to play man
it really was man I like playing in San
Diego
too ain't no way bro I spr MCL our
rookie year uh splitting between grass
grass and dirt I said oh this is this
got to be ille on on the Raiders field
man on the Raiders field like I like God
has blessed me right with with ability
to play 201 one game started 200 of them
like you know have have missed two games
in my career bro I sprayed my MCL on
split rookie year there and then you
know probably like it was somebody
somewhere else with grass I was like
maybe I'm not a grass
guy I need I need my footing so you like
Turf you like Turf I like sure footing
if you could give me grass with better
grass than whatever is that uh Soldier
Field or or Lambo the The Herald of
Lambo like you remember my rookie year
my first game was at Lambo and I was
like oh dang this is Lambo field like
the stories the history the amount of
hate I have for Green Bay because I was
born in Minnesota right my daddy played
13 years of Vikings I hated Green Bay
for as long as I can remember until and
then I sto you know I was like I'm a
Vikings fan until whatever his you Brett
Favre went over to the Vikings I was
like no I gotta step away I was like we
we don't just accept the enemy just
because he CHF for colors right so you
know I was like this is Lambo field
first game and I got there and the grass
was trash and I was like I I like yo
every time we like you know you're
getting speeches at halftime from your
head coach talking about you gotta wear
these type cleats you gotta you if half
inch is enough you got to put you know a
three quarters in when we're were
arguing the the different spikes we're
having in our cleats a different you
know whatever that is in the
cleats Fam I'm trying to I'm trying to
execute at a high level that is
interesting man you know we just talking
about early early in our career you know
playing on on you know the Raiders field
half half baseball half grass man back
in the good days back in 20 back in 20
2011 man we were with very rare company
man um you know not often do you get to
play with your team your whole entire
career man and you are you are
definitely on Pace to do that man how
rare is that I mean I I thought I was
going to be able to do it with the
Denver Broncos but I walked in one day
and they just didn't love me no more and
you are doing it man how does that feel
to be with the same team for over a
decade man um yeah being in year
13 uh you know it it's been a phenomenal
situation to be with the Saints to have
been as uh you know been here my entire
career I've never had to leave I've
never had to think about
leaving I've threatened to retire over
leaving you know like I like ah you
trade me I'll retire how could you I'll
be like gron Kowski how could you trade
me I'm retire bro like that'd be the end
of it but um that's been a huge a huge
blessing you know the Jordan man got 26
years of collective NFL work over two
teams that's it that's that's rare
enough you know like I don't I don't
know too many people from our draft
class like me CAM Hayward Tyron
Smith that's that's it been been with
the same team their entire
careers how many how many draft piur 23
something how is how is that how is that
relationship with your teammates and
your coaches evolve throughout your time
being
there man it was probably like you know
um a mentorship program for me when I
first got to the league you know when
you first get to League it's everybody's
coach coach coach yes coach no coach yes
coach no coach yes coach we'll do coach
yes yes sir no sir yes sir and then you
know you you already just gra
gravitating towards the OG's the John
vilmer the will Smiths the Jimmy Grahams
you know Patrick Yeah P Patrick
Robertson uh Malcolm Jenkins Roman
Harper you're taking any and everything
from him like all right well how do you
study film how do you do this how do you
do this how do you do this to settling
into you know year two year three and
you're like all right this this is the
way that I'm doing things this is okay
this is how I attack my game plan this
is how we get it going I gotta make sure
I draw out all these plays because I'm a
visual learner uh you know so even now
that I got a iPad I still have a
notebook and I'm driving my little
squares and circles even though they
give us the the defensive notebook that
has all that I got to do it myself so
once I write it it's ingrained you know
it's like once I write it out I feel
like I know it once I write it out I
feel like it goes into my mind you know
you learn you learn how to learn as
you're in the league and you also learn
how to talk to coaches and how to talk
to players as you're growing up so right
around year three was a big turnover on
our defense where they got all the old
players bundle them up and sent them on
out of there and next him know you know
year four I was like the oldest 10 year
guy on the team three four one of them
one of them years and it's like all
right well now i' I've learned
everything I could from my OG so this is
the path that we go we keep some
traditions the same defense eats every
Thursday which you you know every
Thursday we go to dinner as a defense is
great you know that's where you get to
know your teammates and it's great that
we're in New Orleans which is you know a
a big city but it's a it's a small city
with big city Fields you know you can
you can Traverse New Orleans to ker ker
BR in 20 minutes you know it's not like
it's not like being in go you go down to
te Texas and it's Plano and Dallas and
downtown Dallas and you know it's it's
all Irving and all these cities that he
takes an hour to get to actual Dallas
from you know what you know about Dallas
man what you know about Dallas man man
you know at one point in time the kid
wanted to be somewhere in Dallas in the
off season um shoot sh may happen one
day but you know it's just we're we're
we're New Orleans field so everything's
cool so as I'm like said as I'm
gravitating towards guys we're keeping
our stuff we're changing things in you
know I get the ox it was like really the
changing of of the sword when you get
the auxiliary cord to the boom box I got
an oxy about year four and I ain't
really let go until about this year I'm
starting to let go they got it now you
know but that that transition of being a
kid to being a a conent pro took three
years you know three years made a pro
bowl never really looked back three two
years it took me to get on the third
down for real and making my own locker
room Vibes you sort of just had you as
long as you're doing the right things
the right way things are going to work
out your way is and the team starts
gravitating towards you and you have to
be able like all right well this is how
I got here this is you have to be
willing to share that's a that's the
biggest part is some you know some guys
come in and they're like no this is what
I do and they keep it there on their own
I think I'm in a phenomenal locker room
it's like oh dang bro oh you got a AC
spray well this is this is machine that
I use this is what I use this is you
know all this other stuff so you're just
constantly getting a open locker room
where you can communicate and talk
things out oh this is this is the play
we're on you know you go to defense
dinner now you know things about your
guys you're talking to them like hey man
how's the kid all cool man when you drop
in that cup of to and you got to do
whatever this is or oh we're running
this dine this is what I need need from
you don't forget to give you know don't
forget to give me that six call when we
go NB tight end whatever that is you
know like it's You're Building chemistry
because each man each year is gonna be
different as you know locker rooms come
and go during during not even from
season season within a season you have
guys get hurt guys come in trade for
somebody whatever it is so it's just
that constant e and flow so being a
leader is just more than hey I got a SE
on my patch it's being able to be a
rally point being able to be you know a
guy that guys can rely upon and as well
as come to man that's that's cool man
how's is Derek car does Derek car ever
come to some of those defensive those
defensive meetings those defensive
dinners no I don't know if he's ever
been invited you know what I'm gonna
invite him this week see if you want to
come chill with the D line I love bro
for some for some reason bro like I love
Derek Carr man like he's never played on
my team never been teammates but I I
love Derek Carr man like I sacked him a
couple of times but I like I love Derek
Carr man I've seen him out I've been
around he was at Max Crosby's wedding
man like I I love Derek Carr man how is
it uh how's it like having dere car on
your
team great dude great dude you know like
especially because we're sort of similar
in that age age aspect of it all uh had
had good success and he just wants he
has that competitive spirit that want to
win um it's it's phenomenal bro talk to
him he's probably at lockers down for me
talk to him every morning when I walk in
and he's so positive you like you could
see the intensity in eyes like I'm like
DC what up baby like how are you I'm
like man I'm good D early in the morning
who need coffee when you got Derek Car
you know like it's just that that buyer
from jump and it's it's great like you
can see it on you can see that practice
like his will like oh what if I I can
hit him here you know we you know you
don't so in our practice you know
whatever it is Scout teams going against
offense where they have whatever our
ones go against our Scout offense and
then we come back our D line is
literally right next to the quarterback
position you know so I'm going over
talking to DC hey man I don't know about
that we would have made that tackle so
we already that friendly Banner there
yeah but you see you see between these
plays how much he wants to win and it's
infectious so even when things don't go
the right way early on this season or
even if they ever do go the wrong way
during the season you're like bro I know
his intention he wants to win at such a
high level like you you can only root
for him like bro it's it's it's always
impressive to see like land on the AC he
left the Green Bay G Packers game he was
like no I'm playing this week like that
very next week he wasn't he like man I'm
he like if I can throw I can throw and
ever since then I'm be like he go get
her like he does like he's just trying
to get to the game he like me hey tape
it up we'll worry about it
tomorrow man that's that's dope man I
love Derek car man and things were
definitely going good for you guys man
you got the dub against the Bears um Tas
ta Hill he went crazy he joins the NFL
10 10 10 Club 10 pass and rushing and
receiving touchdowns he's the first
player to do that in six six years how
impressive is
that he's a Swiss Army Knife Man what
what can he do he need to come over here
and come play linebacker one time come
down here give some defensive snap
because I mean he running he running
Powers he running you know he's he's
throwing tutes he's doing whatever and
he's he's looking for contact I'll give
you that like he don't shy away from
nothing ain't no running out of bounds
he he may see out of bounds and like
meet me before I go out he he he refuses
he such a nice guy you know like he's a
BYU guy so like really really nice kind
person right but he he's looking for
that contact so it's it's it's awesome
to see you probably haven't but have you
ever played with a player like him
before yeah high school you know like
high school you had plenty of kids that
be PT returner then go play fullback and
then you know go be tight end and wide
receiver Le yeah not the not the league
the league nah man you know you every
now and again you catch a a running back
or wide receiver that can you know do a
little wild cat or former quarterback
that you know get a reverse and toss
that thing you know Maham S Type you
know you go ahead sling one downtown and
score a touchdown whatever that is Odell
Beckham when he you know had his little
little toss to Jarvis back then but you
ain't seen it on a consistent basis and
it's not like no go play tight end by
the way oh go play slot oh go go play
this halfback spot you not you're not
seeing all that being filled that's just
I don't know if you're ever going to see
it again man that's that's insane what
what ta Hill is doing man and you really
can't talk about the Saints without
talking about this defense man the
defense has forced a turnover in every
single game this season how does this
defense compare to Saints defenses from
the past that you've played on man I
think I've been on some uh pretty good
defenses I've been on the historic like
a historically worst defense ever in my
tenure on the Saints um but i' rank for
right now it's not a mid-season temp
check because I guess we're what 10
games in nine games in you know um yeah
nine games in we got eight games left I
think that we're we're trending you know
we're trending towards one of the top
defenses I've ever been a part of and
that's saying something because I I feel
like it was it 2019 to 2020 we
were number one or number two
defensively speaking number two maybe uh
in terms of runs per yard yards allowed
per game sacks turnovers all of it um
just a top that that's probably going to
be one of my top defenses um so if we go
out on course this could be the best
defense I've been a part of but that's
again we got we got eight games left I
refuse to just say this is the best yet
because as we all know this is a
marathon this ain't a Sprint you know in
my mind we're we're uh just a little
over halfway through yeah man you you
you know it's definitely a Marathon Man
um you got to you got to stay consistent
over time and Y definitely doing man I I
saw the clip of you sacking Matt Ryan
again on the sidelines on Sunday man you
sacked Matt Ryan like I said earlier 23
times throughout your career that is the
most ever um in NFL history of one guy
sacking another quarterback the most
ever in NFL history by the way um so
they got me so they got me thinking man
and I wanted to do like a little quiz
right um I'm going to name the edge
rusher and and you tell me who is the
quarterback that they sacked the most
and I give you I'll give you some hints
of course um would you would you like to
play this game cam
Jordan all right okay of course I I
start with myself I played in the AFC
West for 11 and a half years or Russell
Wilson which quarterback did I sack the
most Phil Rivers hey of course philli my
guy Philip Rivers with 16 sacks man I
love man I Love Philip Rivers that is my
guy man okay let's let's keep going man
how about Aaron Donald Russell
Wilson Russell Wilson with 16
to Hey Russ Russell Wilson was giving it
up Aaron Donald's was getting him
man like what did I miss I don't know if
I've ever sacked Russell Wilson he he
done got out of my sacks a few times I
remember early in my career man like
Russell Wilson you did not want to play
Russell Wilson man he was not going to
go down easy man he's still tough to
bring down man Broncos are doing good
but let's uh miles so we got miles
Garrett on here is the Cincinnati
Bengals he has the the Baltimore Ravens
and he has the the Steelers the
Pittsburgh
Steelers yeah I'mma go Ben rburg but I
don't I don't know in the AFC there's no
stability wasn't has been inil
there recent he has sacked Joe barl nine
times Joe barl a been in League that
long he sa Joe Barrow nine times
already dang we got okay we got TJ watt
I'm I'mma go with Joe burrow because it
seemed like he giving it up Baker
Mayfield eight and a half times no
Baker three and a half years or
something like that huh I'm saying they
had to get him out of there man he was
gonna break he's gonna break the record
on Baker Mayfield got JJ wat he's
retired now I give you a hint he's
retired
now man that's that's a lot of the Texas
quarterbacks
huh that time uh but he played for Texas
so that can't be it Jacksonville oh I'm
not going to know this one p i g say
pton but like pton was Andrew Luck 11
times right team wrong quarterback I say
man man look like pton was a hard hard
to sack that and Andrew Luck Andrew Luck
was Andrew Luck was hard to sack he was
hard to sack too he he he really was
hard to sack but we got my guy Demarcus
and I I know this one because I Demarcus
this before um he played in the the NFC
the NFC east no I'm G say I'm G say
gotta be Eli gotta be a minute def
definitely Eli 14 and a half times I I
would have loved that Eli standing
around it's just when you get close to
him he just gonna fall I would have Lov
that man for real hey hey give you one
of these quick
ones I'll take one oh touch
them I got I got I got two I got two
more I'mma go with I'mma go with um
another retired great and then we'll go
to one of the young pass rushers that's
that's uh killing it right now Michael
straight hand oh I'mma
say Dam it's gota be it might be a
Philadelphia Eagles quarterback Donovan
MN it is Donovan McNab 14 and a half
times and he had Coy dmir 14 and a half
times so Michael stran he was been going
off of course and one of our young guys
Michael Micah
Parsons um you know in that division but
he has quite a few guys that he sacked
multiple times oh dang he's young okay
Michael
Parsons my God it's probably it's
probably uh Eli Eli Manning Jr at this
point little Daniel
Jones he does have Daniel Jones three
times but he also has Tom Brady three
times Taylor heny three times and he has
Matthew Stafford three times so he's
he's been going crazy he's been busy
it's been quite a week in the league
this week man
um starting out in Germany it was a
couple that had got engaged and right
after the couple had got engaged he
hugged the mascot
first wait a minute oh did she did she
get unengaged the same
day I don't think it I don't think it
would have matter I don't think like
she's crying and stuff look at him said
she said yes he hug the best first he
was excited man he excited he the Chiefs
man Chiefs they had a they had a great
game man it was the first game in um in
in Frankfurt Germany um Kansas City beat
Miami and it was a really good game I
watched the game while we were in um man
where we at I watched the game when we
was in Cincinnati that morning and it
was crazy man it it had to be um one of
the best games of the Season man the
Dolphins they played well but I think
the the score on defense was probably
the determined fact as a matter of fact
it was cuz the Dolphins ended up scoring
two touchdowns and they only the Chiefs
only beat him by a touchdown but this
play was insane it was on the verge of
not being a catch too I don't it might
not have been a catch but the refs
caught it man and they went and scored
and it was amazing play what do you
think about this play and he was high
stepping he he he earned all that and
that little lateral hey that's that's
great awareness that little lateral and
then sort of held on a Tyreek for just a
second to get you because you knew
Tyreek was gonna walk him down Noah he
started High for real he deserved that
everything everything good that happened
to him he deser
that that that was that was a great play
man um Patrick Mahomes after the game he
said the Chiefs have the best defense um
they definitely have a they definitely
have a really good defense they're
they're win a lot of games defensively
um what do you think of uh Patrick
Mahomes tapes and what are your top
defenses in the league right now of
course the Saints are on there the bills
we you know we got some work to do um
but the Saints are got to be on there
and the Chiefs on there so what are the
other three defenses that are running
off that are running off plays running
off great game running off great games
this at this point in the
season man um Bill's got death for sure
y' D line dep you know Jordan Phillips
AJ
Essa uh you talk about Ed Oliver shoot
Ed probably having his best year yet huh
like I I was seeing him do some dirty
work on the inside they got they got
five sa he five away from getting double
digits love that for him AJ too shoot um
I think hey don't you still got Shaq
Lawson over there too y'all got some
depth over there we got Shaq Lawson just
picked up lynval Joseph
too right but who are the who are the
other top three defenses you
have um I'm always gonna put the Saints
up there because I just think there's
we're just star studed I mean guys that
that always gonna get it dear Davis
Tyler Matthews Marsha Latimore uh Marcus
May Paulson Ado just had two sacks I
think he's got or two sa two uh
interceptions um playing phenomenal
course a turnover pivotal turn turnover
on DJ Moore
um I think that if we're not counting us
just because I'm biased maybe but I
think we're leading the league in
interceptions for sure uh which means
eventually quarterbacks are gonna have
to start holding it which means we can
get our sacks back right you know how it
goes hand in hand but so we we we take
that we take that out of there I'm gonna
say Philadelphia Eagles because I mean
shoot even their backups backup is like
a first-rounder them them boys so star
studed at defensive line
and then they got a cold secondary um
then after them I'm probably going to go
with
um I like Seattle Seattle defense too
but I'mma
go with the 49ers defense they just
picked up Chase young over there
opposite of Nick Boza just got a week
you know they got Harr for formerly with
uh with the Philadelphia last year had a
10 piece came over to so that just
bolstered their dline even further they
already had Eric Armstead they got Javon
kinlaw clearly I'm biased I'm always
going to go dline first um but I I love
watching D line play I love watching the
need I think I think Nick Bosa is the
second closest other than Max Crosby
that plays like takes pride in playing
the run and the pass as a defensive end
which doesn't happen much but you know
we just all get mushed into that edge
rusher category um and so when you think
about when you think about that man they
got P Graham over at Philadelphia dang
yeah I'm probably G to say let's gonna
round that one out so you know in no
particular order it's going to be it's
going to be right there I like that too
man the 49ers they got a really good
defense man like you said Chase young um
Nick Bosa and they they Eric arm said
that's my guy man um but you guys are
you guys are playing the Vikings this
week and we have to talk about Josh dos
I'm Josh dos he made his debut after
Ricky quarterback jiren Hall was ruled
out early um what do you think about his
his game that he played um this this
last past
week uh shoot he got a win against
Atlanta
man you saw the clip of him like doing
the doing the snaps under his Center and
he didn't even know his name he put a
cold hand on her like hey bud how are
you you know like I'm about to I'm about
to run this ship now and they got a win
that's huge like that's that's crazy to
think like insert week one no no I got
the offense already
who figure this out without your main
playmaker who Justin Jefferson who may
come back this week and come on man like
you know I think I think he's he's
hitting hitting his lick at the right
time he's been a couple places and it
seems like he he's shined at Arizona and
is now trying to shine at the Minnesota
Vikings I don't like it for us that it's
you know give give me give me a Less
Mobile quarterback because he was out
there toing that
Tater you know sometimes as mobile
quarterbacks they give it up to man so
you just never know man his postgame
locker room celebration um was insane he
had been in Minnesota for 5 days like
you said didn't know the players didn't
know their names I'm sure he barely knew
plays as well man that's just cool to
just see somebody step in and just play
football it shows you if you know how to
play football man you could just plug
and play Man Of course you want to be
able to finetune the plays and stuff but
if you know football man you could just
plug and play
Man absolutely did you see um CJ shroud
go crazy speaking of quarterback CJ
shroud went crazy he's playing at a he's
playing at a MVP level um he had five
touchdowns he breaks a Ricky record for
470 passing yards man I met C CJ CJ sh
was on the vcast at the Super Bowl this
year and I just knew you know you could
just you could just you could just feel
the light feel the energy um I knew he
was going to be a great quarterback in
this league is it's still early but he's
definitely starting off in a very very
um Elite way and I think it all started
for me me I mean I'm sure he'll say the
same thing when he played Georgia um in
the playoffs man he had a really good
game versus Georgia man I think he left
it all out there he was scrambling
around and I think he's uh definitely
brought that into the NFL man and it's
it's really good to see what do you
think about CJ
shr I think uh I think he's clearly uh
helping right whatever they got going
over the Texans from previous years uh
my guy Sheldon rankins speaks highly of
him um you know Will Anderson Jr's over
there speaks highly of him
uh they came in what two and three
respectively when we played him he was
making right decisions not that he was
making you know uh he was doing all the
quick decisions he was taking whatever
they was given and he was making it work
uh and for a Young quarterback I think
that that's probably beneficial you know
as a pass prusher it's frustrating to
you go after a quarterback that you know
is like a read read first or take off
type situation you like those
quarterbacks that go through the
progressions uh but I saw highlights
from this last game was like against
Tampa where it looked like he's he's
growing at a rapid Pace because he's
already starting to look like com more
comfortable in the pocket reading
defenses now like I see a young
guy yeah he is he is uh he is doing
better each and every week man in their
game they had a running back um kick a
field goal for the goal ahead lead think
how much pressure that is like kicker
gets hurt running back got to go in
emergency kicker and he kicked he kicked
look he kicked the field goal for the go
ahead the goahead lead man how crazy
would that be do you think you could go
out there and kick a field goal for the
goahead
leave the fact that I I don't know if
I've ever actually tried to attempt a
field goal I'mma say no but give me a
week and I'mma say yes if you if you
give me in fact give me a day and I I I
feel I feel quite
confident maybe maybe it's false
confidence but I feel like
yes how crazy would that be though like
you seen that Damu do it some years ago
midseason tied up with the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers kicker kicker gets hurt now
you got to go out there and kick the
field goal to go to take the go-ahead
lead Midway through the fourth
quarter Big Time Players show up with
Big Time
plays W Pride my
boy 100% man you know I you know I'm not
I got too much respect for the
specialist man you know some of my best
friends in the league are specialist
kickers punters um long Snappers so I'm
just gonna go ahead and say man that
that definitely would not be me in that
situation man I that's just no that's
you go to you got to know when to draw
the line man and that definitely could
not be me man especially to go ahead
like if we out there you know if we out
there just you know messing around and
you know that's different but driv for
all the beans for all the beans and
whistles like I would not want to be
remembered as missing the field goal for
the go-ahead league I'm just going to
say let's let have let's let's have
somebody else go out there and do that
you know we got all these quarterbacks
and other guys that definitely would not
be vanon man it definitely would not be
me this last week the Raiders fired
their head coach they fired the gym and
they benched their franchise quarterback
Jimmy Garoppolo and this week interm
head coach Antonio Pierce LED them to a
dub how do you think how do you think uh
how do you think um McDaniels feel at
this time man how do you how do you
think that makes that makes uh McDaniels
feel and do you think McDaniels was
really the
problem I don't know I'm glad I'm not a
not part of that locker room you know
what I'm saying like because they look
from from the celebration that we saw
they was smoking cigars fam
so all you need to know they smoking
cigars vibing out in there man hey I'm
black and gold not blacking
[Laughter]
they hanging out the league is changed
man it's changing man it is dope man it
is dope man it is dope man um I think I
think it's
[Laughter]
definitely they smoking cigars man they
smoking cigars man but I think you know
whenever you fire the head coach man
there probably some tension in there you
let go of the head coach it's probably
it's probably a sense of hey man like
let's just go out here and play our
style of football man um you know it's
probably a relief that they have you
know and Antonio Pierce he he definitely
um brings some different energy to the
locker room man and guys just want to
play for you man we saw it um last year
was with it was Jeff Saturday he came in
and you know he did a good job and had a
couple of wins man it's just whenever
you fire a coach man different energies
in the room and you're able to go out
there and play free and they they was
able to get the dub man and I think
that's that has a huge imp impact on the
morale and you know Max Crosby was the
one passing out cigars man so it has the
it definitely helps with the morale and
the vibe and the energy when you when
you uh terminate guys like that M season
but I don't think I've ever been a part
of that I'm just speculating on how that
would feel and it definitely looks like
it feels good over there with the uh
with the Las Vegas Raiders man because
they're having a great time as we can
see from the cigar um celebration it's
been a
controversial it's been a It's been a
real um controversial topic um for a
while now and it came in play again this
Sunday
um roughing a passor and the way that
the refs are calling the ring the passer
calls it is definitely crazy man we have
a refer Pastor play um the the
commanders versus the Patriots right
here I mean what else can you do right
here he failed to decide in everything
I don't know it's insane man what do you
think what do you think what do you
think is going
on I think in the offseason he should
start a charity event up where he
invites referees for some hands because
like somebody owe him his one because
like for you to take this sack away from
him I think that was his first sack of
the year like he's a young kid right
like he he's a young he's a young gun
just got elevated after you ship off
montz sweat and Chase young and his
probably you first whatever it is first
major time roll he gets a sack and does
the right things knee broke fall he
rolls forward doesn't roll like he
doesn't bomb the quarterback you know he
probably asked for consent the way he
like he made sure everything was okay
for him that that they don't want us to
to see like it feels like for defense
you got 14 people against you 11 on
offense and two or three refs that are
out to get each get you for off offens
or defensive holding or roughing the
pass or any given college but it's it's
getting ridiculous you can't a couple
weeks back that hit from Kareem Jackson
on on a receiver that got him suspended
for four games with just a regular
shoulder hit now you got this kid you
know every every couple weeks it seems
like it's one hit that seems normal that
gets either a flag or more from it and
it's like at some point as a defensive
player you you like L but who looking
out for
us yeah it's it's it's definitely insane
man and it's
2023 you could easily pick that flag up
like somebody could you can easily see
that on the screen and say like okay
yeah I called the flag but it really
wasn't a flag like I'm just going to
pick it up there really is no pride in
that like we're affecting the game you
know we're affecting the outcome of the
game and I'm sure he I'm sure he
wouldn't get for that after they look at
it and review it but it's 2023 there is
no harm in just saying and just saying I
made a mistake and just picking up the
flag like there's no harm in that they
actually do it all the time on on uh
pass interference and defensive holding
and all type of calls like there's no
harm in just you don't even have to
review this it doesn't even have to go
to Five Minute review or anything like
that there's no harm in just looking up
at the scoreboard and just saying oh H
yeah you right I was a little bit too
quick right here I was a little bit too
quick on this call right here and there
was really no need for me to affect the
game and you could just pick it up man I
I'm really not getting had a call like
that too in our game versus the
Cincinnati Bengals Tim settle he had a
hit on the guy and it was just
ridiculous that he got a roughing the
passor call but it's all good when Josh
gets him but when everybody else gets
him it's it's like man what's what is
going on man TJ watt had a tweet he said
um what do you want defensive lineman to
do someone please tell me um russan
russan roughing the passer penalties are
are out of control and I agree with JJ W
on this one for sure I really appreciate
you for coming on my show man um like I
said anything that I that I say to you
on this podcast I say to you off man you
are definitely a motivating and
inspiring uh person not even a player
man on and off the football field hey my
guy I appreciate you bro I just want to
be like you one day bro you so positive
towards offensive lineman like you know
running backs you just so positive
towards offense bro I look at them as
the option and you be like this
opportunity to learn more about my my
NFL Breen I'm like hey I gotta I gotta
be more I gotta be like B man hey hey
hey keep being the allstar dad man that
you are man keep being the the Hall of
Fame dad that you are man I might say
man and it's all love and respect man
and I appreciate you Cam thank you man I
appreciate you my guy I'm I'm about to
head to my daughter's practice right now
this week uh Monday night preview we
have the Denver Broncos and I'm not
going to lie I've had this game circled
on my uh calendar since it came out um
not like revenge or anything like that
it's just I follow the N Broncos I'm not
afraid to say that I I this is really I
follow two teams in the National
Football League the Buffalo Bills and
the Denver Broncos and it's not like I'm
going out of my way to do it it's just
my life is still intertwined with Denver
in so many different ways so I pay
attention to the Denver Broncos and the
Denver Broncos play the Buffalo Bills
which happens to be my team so it is a
very special week for me and my family
like I said there's no revenge or hate
or oh I got to go crazy this week
because I feel like that each and every
week um you know I still have so many
different uh uh family members and and
brothers over there and like I said my
life is still intertwined with Denver so
this would be a a very good game um for
not only me but for my family man I know
all of those guys Russell Wilson Justin
Simmons um I'm not sure if if KJ could
be back this week but Brandon Browning
and you know all the guys over there
Kayton Sterns and Josie Jewel and you
know all of those guys man so it's it's
it's uh Jonathan Cooper is good to you
know it' just be good to play those guys
and I think it's just from
a from a standpoint I just know them so
it's not like a Revenge game or anything
like that they traded me to the Los
Angeles Rams and I won a Super Bowl I
don't have ounce of hate in my blood for
the Denver Broncos I love the Denver
Broncos and it would be a great game to
play them on our turf the Buffalo Bills
Turf and the Buffalo
Bills like I said before we C it is not
time to sound alarm but we're getting
close and before we get to that point
where we have to sound an alarm let's
just start winning games right now um
and I think it it starts with me I have
to I have to play better I have to find
a way to be the type of player that I
have been in the past um obviously you
know I'm not all the way yet but I still
feel like I can make an impact I haven't
done that yet but I have to find a way
to to get that done I feel better and
better each and every week that is true
um but I am not back to where I where I
have been or where I where I need to be
so definitely not sound on alarm with
that um it it will come in due time like
what do I look like year 13 like
panicking and and being ungrateful like
man why am I not like you know you just
gotta find a way to make it happen you
know Kobe Bryan's done it LeBron James
has done it you know how come you know I
can't do it so I will find a way to uh
be effective again and I just need to
stay on the same path that I've been on
each and every week I feel better and
better and better and better and
hopefully this will be the week I would
love for it to be the week and to go out
there and get a sack on Russell Wilson
and celebrate for beating the den
Broncos with my guys and it'll be it'll
be a wonderful time to do that so it's
time to get going not time to sound the
alarm yet but we're getting close got
the Denver Broncos this week a very
special game for me and I'm I'm looking
forward to it uh very much so and it is
a it has been an honor and a privilege
to um have this vcast with you guys
again I had Cameron Jordan other today I
respect the man in so many different
ways and I respect you guys the viewers
and the fans and I really appreciate you
guys for tuning in to this week's vcast
see you guys next
week